department of justice is suing the state
of texas over its new abortion law about
two dozen clinics have already stopped
abortion services omar villafranca has
been following this for us omar good
morning
good morning the doj suit puts
constitutionality at the center of the
argument now the law which is also known
as sbh bans abortion after around six
weeks which is before many women even
know they are pregnant and it makes no
exception for victims of rape sexual
abuse or incest it also puts enforcement
in the hands of citizens by allowing
anyone to sue people who help women get
an abortion like a doctor or clinical
staff or even drivers attorney general
merrick garland argues in the suit that
sba infringes on constitutional rights
and long-standing court precedent now
the supreme court recently declined to
block the law but that ruling didn't
address its constitutionality which is
what a federal judge will decide in this
suit texas governor greg abbott did
release a statement he said quote he is
confident that the courts will uphold
and protect that right to life
tony
omar thank you very much